jessica's with us in San Diego hi
Jessica how are you good how can I help
and Christmas right before Christmas my
husband came home and said I bought a
Christmas present for the kids it's a
dirt bike and I said like just in shock
how much was that and he said well it's
only $30 a month so you know and I was
really upset we had an argument and then
Christmas Eve he brought it home from
the store and he said do you want to see
it I said yeah and he had a dirt bike
and a quad and I said what's this quad
and he said well you were so upset about
the dirt bike I didn't tell you that I
got a clod as well well
then the kids didn't like the dirt bike
so he got another larger clod then he
decided he wanted a quad to ride with
the kwid so we now have three and I'm
just really frustrated because we're
like $15,000 in debt and now we're just
spending all this money on other things
that like we have my husband's student
loans and we're getting our tax refund
so I'm just wondering what should we use
for the tax refund what should we pay
off doesn't matter you're going to
continue to be broke yes how you deal to
deal with this core issue right what the
core issue is you're not on the same
page he spends like he's in Congress and
you're the only adult acting like
somebody's upset about it what so how we
gonna fix that I I've been ignoring it
which is not a responsible thing to do
probably not a strategy go away ignoring
it Oh getting it so how long you guys
have been married 11 years okay so
here's the way this plays out after 30
years of coaching people this ends in a
divorce if it's not fixed because you're
going to reach a point that you're going
to go Mount Vesuvius and there's going
to be no dialing you back in
yeah because if you have any self-esteem
whatsoever at some point you're going to
get sick of being lied to and being
drugged financially through the mud and
you're going to punt and I don't want
that to happen so we need to do a
preemptive strike on your marriage
problems is what we need to do now how
do we do that we do you've got to
determine how many times is this kind of
thing happened in 11 years let me ask
you that um occasionally like once a
year not necessarily the last one I can
think of is we just had our fourth child
and we had a Volkswagen Passat and a
truck and we traded in the truck because
we needed a van to fit everybody all six
of us and then my husband was going to
drive the car to work because the car
was paid off the truck wasn't he also
has a motorcycle and and we agreed even
though he really wanted a truck he that
we wouldn't get a new one until his
motorcycle was paid off then he wouldn't
bought a few months later yeah we now
have a truck how old is he
34 okay
he's operating emotionally on about 14
year old level when he does that kind of
stuff and that's why it's frustrating
you feel like his mother and you have a
misbehaving child am i right okay yeah
when he's done he does stuff like that
that's how it has to feel and you
somewhat feel lied to and misled because
you were lied to and misled the lying
parts called we call financial
infidelity where people lie about money
stuff because there's not a quality
process that we can make the decisions
in together because he's worried about
you scratching his eyes out and you're
worried about him breaking the family
and so you know there's no communication
there's a breakdown and so people just
become arrogant and go do whatever they
want to do and that's what he's doing so
bottom line is this if you cannot sit
down and have a very serious
conversation with the television off and
the kids away at school or the kids
asleep at night and say this is
affecting our marriage your misbehavior
with money and us not being on the same
page is going to continue to cause us
problems I am really losing respect for
you as my husband as a man this is I
feel scared because I don't know what
stupid thing you're going to do next
I feel lied to because you have lied to
me and we have got to work on this and
if you don't get a really positive
response to that
the next day you need to call your
pastor or a and or a marriage counselor
and sit down with them if he will not go
you need to go anyway because you need
someone better than Dave Ramsey on the
radio to walk you through this and
because this is not like on a scale of 1
to 10 this is about an 8 right now but
what will happen and again I've seen
this because I've done it thousands and
thousands of times with couples if it's
not dealt with you will go from an 8 to
a 12 all of a sudden you'll just reach
I've had it I'm done and no matter how
many times he apologizes no matter how
many times he says anything you want
you'll be done there won't be reeling
you back and I've seen it before I'm
warning you if that doesn't feel right
it doesn't sound like you it's because
it's not you today but this is going to
go on to a certain point and your fear
and your disgust and you're like a
respect is going to reach a point that
you're just going to punt and I don't
want you to get there I want you to turn
the corner before that so the two of you
if you can't work it out and begin a
positive direction in one conversation
then you need a coach to walk you
through that that's a good marriage
counselor there's no shame in that my
wife and I've been to marriage
counseling there's nothing wrong with
that at all and you get some help and
somebody walk you through how to talk to
each other how to respect each other how
to love each other well and how to work
together on making life's decisions and
you've got to get that going does that
make sense to you when I say that or are
you going to do it
yes okay and he is a good man
I didn't say what a gay man yes I said
when he does those things he's acting
like a little boy and you have to take
the position of Mommy and you wanted a
man you didn't want a boy well now
there's other times that he's manly and
he's a good guy and everything's fine
but occasionally he goes off the ranch
and does stupid that it takes the family
two to three years to recover from
because he's acting like he's 14 years
old there's nothing in morally wrong
with buying a truck or going buying
three quads there's nothing wrong with
that
you don't do that and go in debt and you
don't do that in a lot of your family
you won't lie to your wife and you don't
do that and set the family back years in
its financial progress that's immature
that's 14 years old that's what I'm
talking about and so it's not that what
he's doing that he's not a good man two
other times he's a good man he's worth
saving I'm not trying to put to get you
to bond him
I'm trying to get you work on this so
you don't honey that's my plan and I
think you can do it I think you can turn
this around
but honey how this promise you this if
you continue the current strategy which
is ignoring it it's going to blow up in
both your faces and you're going to go
that all guy in Tennessee told me that
because I just did this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]